hello and welcome to this video playing
tap coos OH
I'm Joan Lee so really late that he's
got a really high rating so I probably
shouldn't have played something that I
don't know all that well just wanted a
bit of what why is that a move it's it's
not good young but why exactly it's too
early
even if I've immediately comes to mind
but
okay so you really - that out very
quickly as though he has a clue but this
is not a theoretical position at all so
Jake here know what happens that nighti
form this this looks this jokes okay
making sure that the response Russia
actually gets damaged Queen takes Bishop
f3
I don't mind that I wanted to go g6
Bishop g7 anyway the bishop has no
purpose on F aid and I want to attack
the weak pawn on d4 not certain yet and
what to do with my King even castling
longest not totally totally stupid maybe
but I mean my working smacking is safe
on the King side so yeah I thought if v
is strong in such a case
okay it's not totally clear actually
this is good to be honest yeah Knight f5
and threatened b6 now b6 is good opening
up okay
I would really like to take with the
piece on v6 and not with the Queen
well rook takes b6 would be nice
so Luke Jack's threatening queen takes
c3 what is the best this and probably
there should be three young I had still
a good move
okay look here
and that's a full scale disaster him and
now takes be three and four would be one
made or would be - okay walk with me -
yeah that opening play I don't believe
in really a c5 is clearly clearly not
good it's just too early not sure how to
punish it what's the best movers I was
even even this comes into consideration
that's kind of thing but I didn't want
to play it or any plate is also quickly
I mean maybe he really has something
weird here in storm
so let's develop if I've already was
good it's surprising how good if five is
apparently according to the engine so
this is strong you and I get this and
you know so this wasn't great thought
that looked quite ok actually but Queen
to b3 was good
yeah this this looks fine for white iam
absolutely so this would have given him
a good position I guess and here the
opposite is probably true in general I
think that was all a bit too ambitious
and now probably ah blundered here i
blundered yeah I didn't see that at all
like this this this all of a sudden it
seems that Queen d8 is still okay for me
even but I didn't see this idea at all
the problem here after this is after
Queen III said this is going away and I
got b6 and that is we're talking about
being lost already my FB Aegis I think
quite good and yeah what this position
is totally falling apart just um just
doesn't work doesn't work okay guys
thanks for watching